chairman Jerrold Nadler and members of
the committee thank you for the
invitation to here today to talk about
my big brother George the world knows
him is George but I called him Perry
yesterday we laid him to rest it was the
hardest thing I ever had to do I'm the
big brother now so it's my job to come
for my brothers and my sisters
Perry's kids and everyone who loved him
and that's a lot of people I have to be
the strong one now because George is
gone and me being the big brother now is
why I'm here today to do what Perry
always would have done would have done
to take care of the family and others I
couldn't take care of George that day he
was killed but maybe by speaking with
you today I can make sure that his death
would not be in vain to make sure that
he is more than another face on a
t-shirt more than another name on a list
that won't stop growing George always
made sacrifices for our family and he
made sacrifices for complete strangers
he gave the little that he had to help
others he was our gentle giant I was
reminded of that when I watched the
video of his murder he called all the
officers sir
he was my old mentor he didn't fight
back he listened to all the officers the
man who took his life who suffocated him
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds he still
called him sir as he begged for his life
I can't tell you the kind of pain you
feel when you watch something like that
when you watch your big brother who you
looked up to your whole entire life died
died begging for his mom
I'm tired I'm tired of pain pain you
feel when you watch something like that
when you watch your big brother who you
looked up to for your whole life die die
begging for his mom I'm here to ask you
to make it stop
stop the pain stop us being tired George
called for help and he was ignored
please listen to the call I'm making to
you now to the cause of our family and
the cars ringing out the streets across
the world people of all backgrounds
genders and races have come together to
demand change honor them honor George
and make the necessary changes that make
law enforcement the solution and not the
problem
hold them accountable when they do
something wrong
teach them what it means to treat people
with empathy and respect teach them what
necessary forces teach them that deadly
force should be used rarely and only
when life is at risk
George wasn't hurting anyone that day he
didn't deserve to die over $20 I'm
asking you is that what is that what a
black man is worth $20
this is 2020 enough is enough
the people marching in the streets are
telling you enough is enough
by the leaders that our country the
world needs the right thing the people
elected you to speak for them to make
positive change George's name means
something you have the opportunity here
today to make your names mean something
to if its death end up changing the
world for the better and I think it will
then he died as he lived it is on you to
make sure his death is not in vain I
didn't get the chance to say goodbye
- Perry while he was here I was robbed -
dead but but I know he's looking down at
us now Perry looked up and what you did
Big Brother you changed the world thank
you for everything for taking care of us
when on earth for taking care of us now
I hope you found mama and you can rest
in peace with power thank you